you actually are though and it's not
even like Target yeah yeah it's just
like facts you're all useless but that's
not like like that's not to say you're
not a good person yeah like gerbils are
useless but we love them you know what
I'm saying
[Music]
that's how you started episode guys that
is how you start an episode welcome back
to the best podcast in the world you're
tuned into your boy Fire Lord Flakes and
my young Gunner young Jimmy come on uh
we also have Ellis The Lyricist editing
Menace in the building we have REM de La
Creme also in the building
yeah IG question hurry up IG question of
the week let's move it forward because
Jimmy's impatient IG question of the
week is what something toxic that you
like in a relationship
oh it sounds yummy it did sound yummy at
the time oh it's not yummy it's juicy
it's juicy but a lot of people said the
same story you know you have to try and
like weed through some [__] to try
and find you know some gems some gems
and we found some gems for you guys
today so what's something toxic that you
like in a relationship
when she cuts her family off for me oh
oh you need me you
got a power don't give me that kind of
power and that's too easy because her
family
oh you know it's flames you know his
Flames yeah
it's different when she pops up at your
job after you've blocked her
that's toxic it's not for me either for
me that sounds like a headache yeah yeah
but right I can imagine I can imagine
you can imagine a certain man that will
tick with him
when she tries to outperform the side
chick
Jesus Christ that's open and honest when
she tries to outperform the side chick
let's open and honest damn I thought it
was gonna be other way around yeah out
before the main but then side chick has
no choice it should also keep her job
she's got she's got no choice yeah yeah
so yeah the main trying to outdo the
side chick
that's a real one yeah that'll make me
second guess my life decisions
yeah she's a real one indeed yeah when
she gets mad because I made the cashier
laugh
laughs
that reminds me of them videos that you
see when there's a copper walking for
example and another lady has dropped a
bag and you give her the bags oh thank
you and the wife is like okay throughout
the whole video you close the doors
oh thank you bro I saw a um yesterday
yeah with some guy was at uh one beach
club with his visit yeah yeah and he
told the waiter oh in 10 minutes bring
me a shot okay and say it's from a girl
the wife grips it she's like yeah yeah
thanks thanks that's it
why are you so mad
why are you so much why are you acting
jealous man yeah it was pretty ordained
anyway relax babes I was just testing
you you just tested you to make sure
yeah see if you still love man and Dad I
don't give that kind of power that's two
songs give me that kind of power not in
public as well oh okay crab song I'll
grab something oh there's [__] out what
do you mean I'm Yours
what do you mean I'm Yours oh yeah
you'll get lips all right back to it
what's something toxic that you like in
a relationship knowing who's watching my
location as soon as I leave the yard
that's not for me it's also not for me
but fair I know yeah I do know um
some girls like that stuff yeah yeah
yeah
I'm like yeah give me that location I
want to make sure you're safe
oh no
when she's on top going crazy then
suddenly stops and says you love this
[__] don't you oh that's a bit of me
that kind of chat right there makes my
senses Scentsy yeah it makes my sense
he's Scentsy
oh my God I love this [__] don't you oh
it stops you know no stuff like that
makes me want to squeeze until rib sucks
yeah oh it does it locks a demon in me
yeah
um do you remember the first Hulk movie
with Eric banner I do remember but I
don't remember if I remember it but they
in that movie they had it where the
Anglia hole gets the bigger again and he
was like fighting the dogs do you
remember
and then one of the dogs bit him he had
these mutant ass dogs
they were like Hulk dogs and one of the
one of them bit him and he got so vexed
that he like popped his shoulder like it
got bigger and bigger and big and broke
the dog's draw it was one of the illest
fight scenes I've seen I can't remember
Bros I've only seen that original Hulk
movie once oh I've seen it a few times
I'm into Cinema I was a kid fair enough
the one not the one is this Tim Roth in
it Oh my Captain who's Tim Roth again
Tim Roth is it the bread I said lie to
me he's in a couple of um no no no no
Tim Roth's in the um the one with Tim
Roth is the Incredible Hulk I think
maybe that's the one I've seen um I
haven't seen the original oh
The Incredible Hulk yeah yeah okay the I
think it's just Hulk might be the first
one yeah this is pretty Marvel pretty
Marvel shouts yeah yeah bro yeah the big
my point being Yeah the more Vex he gets
the bigger he gets okay that's how I'd
feel with that you love this [__] don't
you I'll be squeezing and squeezing and
squeezing squeezing pops the harder I
get the stronger yeah that's exactly how
it would be yeah fair enough fair enough
fair enough all right
um I don't know why but again snatched
out the club by my man is gushy
I bet it is
I'm not snatching anyone out the club
because my pride won't let me none of
this whole I'm not the Chasey boyfriend
yeah yeah I'm not the like you think you
can run around and be a hoe yeah not
under my watch yeah I'm like leave
[__] leave I'll just get in the car
yeah facts yeah I'll just get in the car
yeah but I can imagine I can imagine I
can imagine what do you think you'd do
it yeah over the shoulder
you've been gonna have this much leg out
you're mad we're going I can imagine
yeah it was just crazy yeah
the gifts and dates after I catch him
cheating
that's crazy that's a talk straight she
loves but she's Pat he's got his life
patterned all he has to do you can just
cheat make up and then clap
that's nuts that's the most nothing I've
heard toxic she likes it she loves it
that's crazy when the slaps transcend
outside of the bedroom
wow okay domestic yeah bro domestic V
Bros What She Likes she likes a bit of
DVD yeah DMV a little bit DV that's
crazy that is crazy talk get him bitten
and threatened and not necessarily in
that order
that's
nuts okay when she lies to her friends
about being with me
wrong for you I'm wrong
I'm right for you in all other aspects
wow wow
what you want but what you need right
now I'm gonna crack to you oh God yeah
yeah yeah boy moment on the lips
Lifetime on the hips that's your boy
let's go yeah yeah yeah yeah Juicy Lucy
all right when I don't pick up his face
time so he texts me saying you don't see
me calling you what the [__] you doing
yeah I'm seeing a running Trend yeah
yeah
they want a bossy boss they want to
trembled yeah yeah yeah they really they
they enjoy it yeah they want they want
to be Rapunzel just in a in a castle go
[__] move don't [__] move until I
say so now until I can't [__] say so
it's crazy keep your head out of the
[__] window
get ahead in a [__] window
foreign
criminal past but treats me like a
princess Jesus man when he humiliates me
in public that [__] has me dripping
Define humiliation
Define humility and expand that's what
she said because I will make you Buckle
if you want to get gushy I'll kick the
back of your ear
that's crazy
all right next one codependency I love a
[__] who can't live without me
this is literally a running thing that
is
damn it is it really is all right if I
swing on him and he restrains me sexy if
I swing on him and he lets it connect
ick
[Laughter]
that's it that's bad that lets it
connect sweetness she just swings from
man's drawing and she's like yuck yeah
yeah she just let me bang in your face
but if you restrain me I'm yours yeah
hold her there yeah what do you think
you're doing come on man
yeah all right I've got a few more
when he uh when he can make me beg for
forgiveness even though he was in the
wrong
this I'm gonna let you man no no this
thread's bringing out the worst yeah
he's bringing another dude I'm not proud
yeah yeah I'm not saying wow I feel like
I just ate a devil fruit
I'm salivating here wow
when no means yes every single time
hmm
begging for a cream pie when he knows
I'm not in any contraception
that one I'm gonna wrote that myself
that one there that's
I will turn Super Saiyan in there I will
turn Super I'll still pull out but I'll
turn Super Saiyan in there that is crazy
when he knows a lot in any contraception
he says daddy [__] me I'd lose my
mind
and lose it all yeah I couldn't hear
stuff either I'd lose it all that's yeah
that's how you get trapped so you have
to that's how these NFL Dawns get Fox
that's how all these men get trapped
yeah two words [__] me
Gan please men are so weak when when our
senses men are so weak
such a nightmare and it's so pathetic it
is but you can't help it and your thing
is when you're in it you know what
you're doing it how wrong it is it's
sweeter and it just it just oh it just
makes so much sense for those seconds
as soon as it's done you're like wow I
need to reverse everything that has
happened bro I wanna drapes the Dyson
immediately oh my God just just clean up
just can't continue but then next week
I'll run it back oh God yes we're weak
bro yep thick all right I've got a
couple more uh what's something toxic
that you like in the relationship when
she uses her talents instead of
apologizing and taking accountability
just hair time yes yes you know what
time it is you just know what time it is
don't be mad at me hair tied up looking
up yeah they're looking up yeah yeah
say less
but I hate this thread go on finish up
pause last but not least
when my man gets jealous and threatens
to kill people nothing makes me feel
more feminine
this is crazy every girl wants a bad man
and a soldier yeah bro that's all I'm
hearing every girl wants a bad man and a
soldier but welcome to the show guys
welcome back guys
living rooms are quiet and they're
partners are looking at each other
oh Jesus yeah if I yeah if I was
watching this with the love of my life
yeah banging it or facts cream pie me
even though he knows I'm not in any
contraception and if home girls watching
I'm here like
yeah yeah I'm doing what's what's that
movie called
bro close again
Bruce Almighty yeah the warranty in the
sofa's about to yeah yeah mad
anyway introduce these guys man so guys
welcome back thank you for coming back
to episode 32 uh five or seven whatever
five three two five three two three two
five this is this is three two five yeah
yeah yeah Pang episode three two five
guys welcome back thank you for uh
joining us today you already know the
drill guys if you love this show if you
really love it don't just pretend to
love it if you really really really
really really love the show and you want
to watch more of the show head on over
to patreon.com forward slash Jason you
can binge multiple years worth of
content over there and when you're up to
date every single Thursday we drop a
bonus episode on there
that no one else gets to see facts in
the very soon like next week I think ad
free content we're adding to patreon as
well so if you love our YouTube episodes
if you love our Spotify episodes
head on over to patreon it's three pound
a month run the P to s g and you can
have an ad free experience behind the
scenes experience Discord experience
Zoom call experience close connected
Community with your daddy's just here
okay in that Triple C say Less close
yeah come on come on yeah Boys on
foreign
[Laughter]
hilarious that's what your boys on oh
anyway
wow what's going on today
jokes
um I'm sweating I don't know about you
I'm sweating [__] oh man [__] [__]
sake um anyway guys if you're watching
us on YouTube please subscribe to the
channel chaps a thing in the comments if
you fancy yet yeah if you are uh
listening on any other pla uh audio
platform please leave a nice review it
means the world to us and we sincerely
sincerely sincerely appreciate it
um
before we get into the top five talk to
me Daddy I've got a thank you I know I
never say thank you you never do never
do that come on you're welcome sir
[Laughter]
wow it only took four years yeah all
right bet I don't know what to say
imagine
okay anyway where was I oh where was I
blood clots anyway
so
Daddy got his uh body fat percentage
done today okay with his PT
at you
I'm gonna be honest with you Matt I'm
not gonna tell you about what the
percentage is
but that is a little chunky monkey okay
yeah
um I'm not impressed okay
so
um All I'm gonna say is
I did it the old school yeah when I say
grab my stomach I'm doing it myself
that's violation I'm not being violated
that like that in years that's a
violation man Tommy lift up my thing and
drapes oh hold on my team yeah yeah like
this
I didn't I said yeah just on the left
just grabbed it pinch a [__]
yeah took it
did the weights did the measurements all
that check the thing
the the percentage number I saw
Wow fight you okay so
I said it before I'm gonna keep saying
it yeah ends today okay
this let's listen you might laugh it up
okay the next time you man see me naked
yeah I'm gonna have that yummy tummy the
next time you [__] see me naked
you're gonna say that's that yummy Tom
say less so Daddy yum Tom is where we're
going for the rest of this year okay
Daddy yum time is where it's at okay
because I'm gonna get I'm gonna slice
that percentage in half okay and
um I'm half that washboard yes lickable
okay um so that's that's why I'm at okay
that's where I need to be at cool daddy
yum Tom 20 rest 2023 because I was I was
appalled yeah when you when you're
um like faced with your own fear like
that yeah you've got no choice but to do
something about this fact as well
because this is science we're looking at
this is not how I feel it it's not
you're made up this is not me in the
mirror with waistband marks thinking
what's going on
there's nothing more humbling than
looking at yourself naked in the mirror
bro there's nothing in this world facing
up just red waste my marks all over me
thinking what is this that's one thing
but when science says you're a little
bubble yeah science proves yeah yeah
yeah yeah a little puffy jaunt
bro it will wake you out it'll wake you
at your sleep
oh we are trained after that okay bro I
hit uh incline dumbbell press
4E I think we did the 40 42 kilos nice
uh four sets of eight clean nice I could
have done a fifth set nice well strong
today good that 10 new bro that tummy
time woke me the [__] up okay so I'm on
it from now okay I mean I've been on it
yeah but I'm on it on it even more
carrot sticks and hummus that's what
your boy's on okay say let's bro the
worst feeling I felt say that to get
pinched and hurt like that yeah and then
hurt again like that yeah humiliation
I'm not on it I can imagine uh anyway
top five top five indeed um remind us of
the scores Ellis please sir it's getting
boring don't you call you man can't let
him say that say stuff like this right I
might take a week off
it wouldn't make a difference I might
take a week off
hey let's watch the scores please
thirteen seven three thirteen seven
three all right all right bet wow last
[__] opponent [__] ridiculous
right guys you know the drill at home
grab your board markers or whatever or
play in your head however you want to
play but as per usual it's time for top
five top five top five and the top five
of this week is
we've done most followed on Instagram we
are now doing the most of other people
on Twitter
and your time starts now
uh right we all locked here yeah you're
right uh since your first Jimmy can you
give me your top five so my top five is
um I have no ego when I lose this by the
way I don't know I've done Selena Gomez
Taylor Swift
Elon Musk uh Ariana Grande
and I've done the rock as well uh REM
I've gone Kylie Jenner
Cristiano Ronaldo Elon Musk The Rock
and Twitter
yeah it's where it probably is Alice
so I've gone for Elon Musk
I've gone for Kanye
because I could shout I know his streets
used to blow up didn't even come into my
head good [__] shout
um also on top of that Donald Trump also
another good chance to tweet a lot of
stuff
and then these two are better there
Pokemon
I remember stuff you used to come out
about it all the time yeah on Twitter
huge huge stream and um Belle Delphine
as well
because she again your little hornboard
kicking off top five corn
say less all right just for a recap
Jimmy's gone for Selena Gomez T swizzy
Elon Musk Ariana Grande The Rock REM I
was gonna say Kylie Minogue Kylie Jenner
Ronaldo Elon Musk the mosque mosque The
Rock and Twitter X or whatever you want
to call it uh Alice has gone for Elon
Musk Kanye Trump Pokey Main and Belle
Delphine
Riley Roo I heard beldofin had has or
had an only fans I swear she was making
like a Miller month yeah remember it's
just kicking off yeah
we spoke about this I don't even spoke
about on the show but we spoke about the
cinema
right uh number 10 is Lady Gaga oh Fair
it's number nine is one of you wrote
this down
Donald Trump
you men always get disappointed when
it's not top five I I'm usually like
Fair Play Because the amount of times
that we've had none in the top five yeah
and it comes down yeah it comes down to
it true yeah
uh number eight never heard of this
person Narendra Modi said
um
Indian brother no idea or Narendra I
could be a female I have no idea
um number seven tea swizzy
okay cool cool cool
number six which no one wrote down Katy
Perry
okay surprising yeah that's weird who
cares about Kate Perry same Lady Gaga
who cares who still cares about these
people Millions upon millions millions
upon Millions people
um where was I I said Katy Perry number
six right all right number five now
we're down to it number five is Rihanna
didn't even come to my head number four
which only one of you wrote
is Cristiano Ronaldo well I played
around I was gonna write Cristiano but
you didn't
foreign
which nobody wrote is Justin Bieber I
was thinking Justin Bieber number two
again which nobody wrote
controversial Barack Obama really yeah
Barack Obama's number two on Twitter
yeah yeah damn that that's okay damn
yeah okay
and number one
everyone wrote this
Elon Musk Ram one
so REM actually did win this one well
played right well played well played REM
it's about time it's about time so it's
13 8 3 I believe GG yes damn bro 1383
I thought I thought I've just literally
thought of one when you were reading so
I was gonna I should have bought well
it's not in anyway but I thought Pierce
Morgan because he's really controversial
uh I don't even think that he's even the
top 20. he probably won't be in because
I know I don't reckon he's top 20 pissed
off on YouTube and stuff but he doesn't
he does rub people at the wrong way he
see what you're going with that but
that's what I was trying to when I was
writing my answers down I was trying to
think of
yeah stuff where like people have been
pissed off or yeah Kanye and Donald
Trump are definitely those kind of
people yeah man for sure
okay guys let's take a very very very
brief pause to pay some bills right guys
fresh ball full is upon us okay breathe
it in fresh ball full
and you need to be in the festive Spirit
light a candle get some pumpkin spice
and make sure your balls look nice with
the sponsors of today's show you guessed
it wasn't difficult manscapes come on
nature may clear the leaves off the
trees but you'll need manscapes help to
get ready for that sweater weather okay
get your pants puppies prepared for
coughing season with a trim as
refreshing as a full Breeze by going to
manscape.com and using these special
unique exclusive one-time code sng
Sierra November gold for 20 off plus
free shipping let's get back to it is
there right so fragsy finally watched
top boy oh yeah bring up the characters
for me please sir on the screen and let
me dissect this [__] I completely agree
with what you've said about
um the Irish tank it was pointless the
only reason why there was a point to it
was because that was the only way they
can get the money again because of is it
when Jack took the money or whatever
that was the only reason they could get
because they needed that they needed
money because something else happened
with one of their shipments or something
so they stole the money that but the
plot was average in that in that region
yeah but they only stole the money back
the Irish brother took that because it
wasn't money it was product products
yeah yeah so the Irish butter took it
from the Moroccans Moroccans yeah which
they were working with anyway so they
could have easily just had a normal
shipment yeah put it in the yacht's yard
yeah and then Jack took it yeah yeah
true true we could have just
true moved off the um yeah anyway the
whole storyline for Stefan was poor the
whole thing should have been related to
Brown Stefan and his brother getting a
bit of at least a bit more revenge
against Sully yeah yeah they were
showing us his [__] relationship with
some little you and like when when they
were actually like kissing and stuff and
everything like why are they showing us
these are actual kids actual children
this is weird as [__] no one cares about
this them walking and talking in a
parking new [__] this is not
character development this isn't growth
for me I want revenge it's top boy for
God's sake we're watching like love [__]
it was that in itself I didn't I'm not
gonna I didn't mind you that much I
minded it a lot yeah I minded it a lot I
think it was a bunch of [__]
that much man I remember what it was
like yeah like I like stuff that reminds
me of like the whole like I personally
don't have a this doesn't bode well from
what I was saying last week I don't have
an issue with like kid Love Stuff let's
obviously if he's [__] her on camera
when they're like underage kids that's a
bit much lips and stuff like that and it
doesn't like it doesn't bother me if
they're kids because I'm not it's not
it's not there to turn me on yeah I get
that but that happened in like the third
episode and I'm thinking all of this
[__] for him should have been done in
the first episode he is the he's he's
the one that saw his brother again
and we're showing him like living his
life not going to school being in his
care home thing and then dating some
chick and like what what they're talking
about yeah one thing I will say is they
definitely didn't pick a lane with him
they didn't they needed to either be
romance revenge or this roadmounting
yeah they did all three yeah he could
have just done the road man and revenge
that's all it needed Revenge could have
been the whole thing all it needed to be
secondly the the mum of the daughter
that Stefan was
um Lincoln sure I don't know who gave
her a pay raise this season yeah but she
was everywhere
reason what's her name Mandy or
something I can't remember yeah yeah she
was everywhere everywhere for no reason
that was such she was a a pointless
character in my opinion and it didn't
add or bring anything to the show in my
opinion again in the big sorry to cut
you off bro but in the beginning as well
when they did this whole protesting for
my manual to get sent back to Botswana
or whatever who cares yeah yeah that
they just that was the dumbest first
episode ever yeah because it was a bunch
of [__] yeah it was all fluff yeah I
just ah that infuriated infuriated me so
much who else what other plots were the
thing with Jack never would have
happened
it never would have happened in real
life like if this was wrote Jack would
never do that yeah the whole like
daughter like sister she didn't I think
yeah she didn't go off the rails enough
with her sister's death
to justify this crazy of a move facts
and then she didn't even make it to the
corner shop before she changed her mind
it's like and it was it was crazy it was
crazy bro um I'm trying to think what
other characters or what whatever
situations pissed me off
um
what did you like bro
I liked a few bits I like I liked
I feel like I only liked
um bits of the storyline IE with
obviously descent to Shane and Sally's
little beef between themselves I feel
like that was good I did like Jack's
character in general as per also as per
as per yeah I think she was hard as
personal yeah she's always good in it
yeah yeah
um I liked
um I didn't like the fact that the
brother was out of it um Stefan's
brother I went to Lee's not nothing
Aaron yeah
Shelly's daughter just disappeared
um remember jelly had a daughter in the
season before
she wasn't there oh yeah she spoke about
it yeah but she wasn't in it she wasn't
there yeah yeah
um and they didn't even show anything to
do with
um Is It Michael the brother Michael's
death
um no Jamie Jamie Jamie his real name's
Michael I believe
um Jamie yeah like they didn't show
anything oh yeah he's not his funeral
not not bringing out the body not
nothing yeah yeah he's just not in it
nothing and the only reference we had
was when Stefan went to the bench to
talk to his brother yeah yeah that's all
we had like bro there were so many plots
that were just so poorly in my opinion
poorly written and I thought it was
because of this writer strike that's
been going on oh okay but then I checked
who wrote those episodes majority of the
episodes were written by the same guy
that wrote the rest of all the other
Seasons oh okay and I remember seeing a
tweet
um post the release of this episode um
this season
I can't remember if it was by
um
uh Ashley Waters or not but it's
something along the lines of
um I think the storyline would have been
different if it was written by a black
person
uh right I saw a few things about that
because there was a clip with yeah with
um Ashley I didn't see the clip but I
saw it was like play the video and then
the title was oh he feels
um if it was of a black writer it would
have been different like
stuff like that Jaws me sometimes
because like it just like there's
nothing wrong with having that opinion
but it needs to be substantiated with
something yeah of course like under like
one why like I is it was one thing to
say like it would be different if they
said like ah I actually feel like if the
writers were from ends white black
whatever if they actually grew up in
this lifestyle they might have written
things a little bit different but just
to say black just in general black yeah
it's like what are you talking about
what is she talking about I hear that
because it's not like because like there
isn't it that would make sense if this
if this is a show about racial
discrimination or things that black
people go through that you have to have
a black perspective to understand not
everyone in the show is black yeah yeah
yeah so it's like it's not even one of
them yeah so stuff like that confuses me
I feel like they were using that as a
scapegoat to
find a different narrative because they
knew this writing this season's writing
was dead Fair do you see what I'm saying
and in comparison obviously you said
your REM you said you're on season one
I'm way behind bro like when once you
catch up to this one you'll realize what
I'm saying about how poor the plot was
for this season comparison to the others
because you didn't really need to watch
I was when I was watching it I said to
myself I didn't really even need to
watch the past two seasons to understand
what's happening because they're not
even following do you see what I'm
saying they're just doing stuff they're
just doing stuff
they're just doing stuff they had an
opportunity to make six brilliant Game
of Throne level episodes for this kind
of show I mean [__] it yeah in my
opinion they [__] they didn't pick any
lanes whatsoever they did like three
riots in six episodes for who yeah yeah
yeah who cares bro yeah it's like they
it's it seemed like to me they needed to
I don't want to say whether they did or
didn't do it they needed to reverse
engineer the writing like what's the end
what's happening at the end yeah and
working and then where are we now what's
happened on the end and how are we like
how are we getting there yeah because it
seemed like they just had like 11 things
going on and then all ended up like all
these 11 paths all ended up to this one
thing yeah none of them were connected
in any way it's just 11 completely
different stories that ended up with
suddenly getting shot at the end yeah
the one one thing that took my breath
away of course was um yeah
when Shelly when Shelly came back to the
yard and deshane obviously has really
murked my man his lawyer wherever it was
yeah and he's on by the sink just
huffing and puffing and he said what's
wrong what's wrong what's wrong uh we
can talk about is it the money blah blah
Did you get it he's like [__] the nail
[__] yeah I burst out laughing fat but
[__] the nail [__] I just lost 2.1 M
yeah bro [__] that no 50 16. I lost 15
M's just talking about 2.1 yeah [__] the
nail shop
that made me laugh as well because I was
thinking bro my life's over my life is
on the line and you're talking about
some nine bar petty [__] yeah yeah
yeah what the [__] yeah oh oh so sweet
and when he tried to when he tried to
re-up it when he got the money back and
he said it was like ice over I'm going
packing the stuff and whatever and he
said oh is this about the nail bar thing
he has no respect for sure he actually
does it is
he basically said [__] you in your life
fax and then when she's upset he's like
what's wrong what's wrong is it is it
about the stupid little nails
I'll get all your money man I've got the
money man Charlie say less [__] it oh
come on why are you crying all the time
but yeah that those two points sweeter
the life out of me oh yeah bro sweet
that was good
um the amount of tick tocks I keep
seeing of the replay of the I want to
give you the money you're a liar you're
a liar
hilarious the memes are funnier than the
show yeah yeah yeah
are so much more funny than the shark
even though the show's not meant to be
funny but you know what I mean man yeah
like um
it was it was mad as well as like the
whole like even the bitworth was
suddenly being pulling up on him and
being like you're retiring right now
he didn't retire for [__] he didn't he
didn't he's retired for like half of one
episode yeah and every single time he
was like I'm rolling I'm rolling I'm
rolling and there was no real
reiteration of suddenly being like big
man I told you every time shut the [__]
up you're not brought into nothing yeah
would say one time I'm rolling oh fine
and it's just like what was the point in
it then there was no point in even
saying he's retired yeah like it was
just ah it's so much irrelevance in the
show but they could have made it so much
better considering it's the last one and
we have to now depict who actually
killed Sally or whatever whatever in my
opinion it was Jack 100 yeah yeah that's
why I thought it was Jackal Irish
retaliation because nothing happened
with that no there's no there's supposed
to be this massive hard gang yeah true
no clap backs the amount of murders that
go on in this show untouched yeah yeah
yeah yeah true the justice system in top
boy in the top of universe the justice
system in the top ball universe is
Western swarm
swarm yeah
yeah she she just oh so she goes on a
map she kills people oh yeah okay fair
but yeah that was my top boy breakdown
um average average bet
um okay uh REM trash news for us please
your boy
so
the man who died without knowing what a
woman looked like
a Greek Orthodox monk Mahalo tolotos I
think lived his entire life of 82 years
without ever seeing a woman due to the
strict rule of the monastery he lived in
on Mount Athos which banned women from
entering he was abandoned as an infant
and adopted by the monastery he never
left the walls of the monastery
throughout his entire life despite
living in seclusion mahalo's story is a
reminder of the strict rules and
regulations that governed the monastic
life in the past
now
obviously first I was livid for him but
you can't miss what you've never had
yeah I was gonna say
um
in harmony Tranquility
the comments are saying he lived in
peace yeah yeah fam there was nothing
going on in his life that was going to
bring him stress or nothing like stress
but joy
but
my mind's just thinking outside the box
here so there are people in this um what
do you call it it's a monastery in the
monastery but he only he didn't see a
woman no none of them have seen it but
women aren't allowed women aren't
allowed but he was he was abandoned and
as an infant and left at the door of
this Monastery yeah so most people turn
up there yes
that's what I'm saying like a couple of
them I could have informed my mother
you're missing out do you see what I'm
saying yeah that's the only way I could
see him deep in the need to see what
he's missing out on as opposed to this
Tranquility thing even though he's going
to believe them though because they're
there with him
never
at the same time I would have an innate
something you don't know what you don't
know what it is they're missing it but
at the same time I'm thinking by the
time you turned about
I don't know say 13 14.
the morning glories that Mama must have
been getting he sucked someone off I
promise you without promise without even
realizing
he saw starving his cheeks and his brain
couldn't make sense of it yeah yeah
someone's touched his sense
there's no way he made it all his life
going through hormones of a teenager
just horny as [__] and didn't clap
someone's cheeks he's ejaculated
somewhere yeah so he needed to go I
promise you he's seen he's seen a grown
man's
uh yeah his his bunions
and said [__] his brain just just
connected the dots yeah I said that's
that's what's waking me up in the
morning
he's banged one of the Breads in there
I'm telling you that's crazy
um Jesus right what the what the
comments zoom in for me please
happiest man to ever live yeah
um he lived the most peaceful life of
any of us
all the guys who get cheated on post
about how happy he must have been raw
bro
that's jokes facts
[Laughter]
to do a kind of convoluted way to say he
died a virgin but go off I guess
people who comment say the most crazy
[__] yeah I bet he's funny parties
bro
happy life yeah man all right man fair
enough don't play to him here's what it
is but yeah I that's not a life I'm
trying to live yeah
but you don't know you don't know what
bodies are you don't know what a BBL is
you don't know what double these are bro
they've not been put in your face before
so what are you missing
he could never
see a BBL
Ade
and break a pavement I never returned
nah he's never returned into that Dunya
a BBL you've never seen a team before
that's crazy
full tea as well nah of course oh you'll
collapse you wouldn't even break the
pavement
that's jokes wow
wow last long that's too much that is
too much bless him all right cool
um somebody [__] am I
um my mother 55 I male 22
have always had a rocky relationship but
I stay I still stay with her and her new
husband because I can't live on my own
as my salary doesn't allow it
um context
um lives in South Africa
um she assistant I pay three bags rent
obviously in their currency and my
salary is only five bucks
I don't need sorry I don't mind doing my
part in the house as I understand
inflation is bad though I'm trying to
save up money for my studies next year I
have no credit I won't be granted any
student loan
over the years she's accumulated debt
Beyond her ability to pay back and I
feel she's using my rent to pay off her
debts instead of using it for the house
we are instead of using it for the house
as we barely make it to the end of the
month
She was recently diagnosed with cancer
and she feels like she feels more
entitled than ever to make to take my
money for any and all reason the company
I worked for paid out my leave
settlement which was approximately
around 20 bags her car in Brackets the
only one we have broke down and now she
can't go for keema provided by the
private medical insurance I pay for
in Brackets 55 she's had a good run in
my opinion
she's had a good run in my opinion
it's going to cost about 15 and a half
bags to fix the car
I work from home and I couldn't be asked
about the car she's hinting at me to pay
for the repairs
I didn't want to tell her about the
money I got from work but she overheard
it in a conversation which I had with my
manager she likes to eavesdrop
am I the answer for not helping them fix
the car as they want to use the money
for my studies
okay first of all
sorry your lips are twitch first of all
this
use it for my studies shut the [__] up
okay shut the [__] up that's such a
throwaway comment like
to balance small High Ground yeah okay I
want to use it for my studies like what
um excuse me
and with everything that's going on
we're not talking about studies your mum
can't go to chemo yeah yeah yeah yeah so
so Matt said
I'm concerned that she's using my rent
money to pay off her debts and I'm fixer
by it because we're not making it we're
not barely making it a month yeah
a car broke down and she wants me to pay
for it but since her car broke down she
can't get to chemo but I don't need I
don't need this [__] car yeah so why
am I paying for it yeah and she's 55
yeah yeah she's had a decent life yeah
this is mine yeah yeah yeah
um yeah he's the [__] oh [__] this is
like this is not of a discussion the man
said chemo Kimo shimo long story short
business this chemo has nothing to do
with me yeah she's had a good run it's
crazy wow 55 I think she's had a good
run that's crazy you're you're ex like
you're basically God's calling you and
you're airing him go
discarding is a sign go go and die
that's that's too much it is too much
and all of this is when he can't afford
his own yard yeah from when you can't
afford your own yard and you're kicking
up stink like this shut the [__] up yeah
literally shut the [__] up because it's
all this like why should I have to do
this watch after this why should I have
to do this your mom can Turf you up
tomorrow in your [__] thanks so
literally I can understand sometimes as
a child like when you have to when you
feel like your parents should be looking
after you and you have to start looking
after your parents when you're not
mentally in that state yeah I can see
sometimes when it's frustrating and
you're finally getting money like you've
never had money yeah as soon as you
start getting money
I can imagine that is the most
frustrating thing yeah of all time yeah
but quick like
get your priorities straight your mum's
got cancer let's sort it out yeah I feel
like him being 22 I don't think he
realized how much he still needs his
mother in his life
you can't even afford your own yard and
you're living in your mum's house stop
crying facts because you both need each
other
yeah yeah oh she's taking all my money
for rent and she's using it to pay off
the thing it doesn't matter I don't know
what my landlord used my rent for you
can use it to do whatever the [__] he
wants I sharp and I pay the rent so I
can keep a roof over my over my head so
don't be worried about what she's
spending the money on my my bro
ah yeah but yeah open a shop there's
nothing I need to add I just had to read
it out [__] you know what little belly
audacious little bell and audacious you
are the awesome you're a bomb boy yeah
yeah boy [__]
that's a new insult from now yeah that
is the sng official Insight little
[__] bottom boy right now anyway so
you've got a thread for us for hat I
have got a threat so the thread is
when did you realize your supposed
friend actually hated you this was all
over Twitter this is my thread that I
had as well I'll swear yeah yeah yeah
yeah I've got I've got pictures and I've
got the thread as well so you might as
well just lump it lump him in this one
as well all right bet let me find it
I've got pictures when she moved in with
my boyfriend saw that one brazy not
funny brazy right this one sweeted me
all right hit me man said
I lost bear in mind right quick quick
pause this is a South African friend
yeah yeah yeah these man was spit in
Swahili right [__]
oh I couldn't keep up with it I could
not keep up with sound effects bro sound
effects
fan clicks Galore Universe
English half mouth noises South Africans
we love you yeah we love oh you love us
yeah yeah make it easy for us we're
trying to help you help us I wanted to
read in here but half of it was just
sorry chipperary I was literally going
to say gibberish because I can't it
can't translate read it it was pissing
me off it starts off juicy and then you
just bear and then someone will comment
oh [__] hey you know it's juicy yeah
because they're all kicking off
right so anyone this one
lost my car in 2021 yeah
this bread couldn't wait to tell people
how my car got repossessed because I
couldn't afford it
we saw a similar car and he said
remember when you were driving that
thinking you were a mayor
he said everyone burst out in laughter
[Applause]
oh that's an inside that's an insult
could never speak to me like that do you
remember when you had that car you
thought you were the mayor
oh
oh that'll make me scream that's so
condescending yes oh Beyond you remember
you got that car you couldn't even
afford and you thought it was a [__]
big boy
now look look at you
boy [__] facts bro oh God all right go
on uh when a friend said to me even if
you upgrade your qualifications you
won't find a job
you don't believe in me you don't
believe in anything you can be as
qualified as you want you're not gonna
you're not gonna get a job why would
anyone hire you bro why would anyone
hide oh I don't talk to people like that
right this one's sweetened me
so we attended her boyfriend's we
attended her boyfriend's Friend's
Wedding okay
so they booked us a room at guest house
because the wedding was uh 40 kilometers
from town okay and we'd be drinking from
the Friday okay
on the Saturday in the wee hours we
decide uh to go and sleep because we
were sloshed
15 minutes later the boyfriend comes in
my head I'm thinking he's just coming in
to check on us they start making out and
next thing she's touching me too
oh Jesus fair enough
all right when she got drunk and started
telling me how useless I was in her life
can you imagine
bro we just get tipsy and I'm opening up
having to open it up and you think it's
it's the safest the safest places
judgment free and I start saying bro
thank you so much for the last few years
everything's like bro I'm not gonna lie
to you you're just irrelevant you've
been so useless and useless in my life I
love that we have the kind of ratio
where I can just say these things but
like you're just so useless I can't ah
and I'm like and then when you're like
what no no no no no no no no no let me
laugh you actually are though and it's
not even like Target yeah yeah it's just
like facts you're all useless but that's
not like like that's not to say you're
not a good person yeah like gerbils are
useless but we love them you know what
I'm saying you're [__] useless bro
but hey save space yeah save space and
all that but yeah oh my God
I'm assuming this is the girl's name
it's a kanji okay that one had my girl's
number saved as Target on her phone
wow
Target wow wow imagine I couldn't wow
Target Target okay that's um wow
secret agent that's a betrayal she's
thinking you're not my brethren you're
my man
and this [__] is a target
wow that's crazy women will actually
save [__] in their phone yeah yeah they
will actually just save numbers as crazy
crazy [__] one wherever they want and
it's just They Don't Fear the
consequence of anyone seeing it
yeah it's crazy
um when she didn't tell me that her
friend was dating my boyfriend behind my
back
how do you even digest that
so that's
rem's banging your girl and I know about
it and I'm just not saying anything
you're just gonna say it literally
nothing to do with me it's literally
nothing to do with me that's disgusting
in in all aspects is disgusting I wonder
who to trust anymore I'd have to live in
a bungalow by myself
because I'll be sorry for [__] wait
ready stairs for bro I need a one-way
passage [__] what he stands for
oh
Jesus Christ oh Jesus right
when she didn't tell me that my girl was
seeing someone else more wealthier well
facts bro spell fast spell and then keep
your girl facts
more wealthier all right the day he got
married and never said a word to me
until I saw it on Facebook after the
wedding
you could never get married you can
never get married post the poster pics
and then me see I'm just rocking to work
on Monday and just me see on Facebook of
all places happiest day of my life
Hab is there my love with the people
that I love oh I would be so offended
can understand the feeling I would feel
feeling grateful
to all who attended feeling great I
would be so official yeah there's
nothing that I I you couldn't tell me
anything topsy-turvy there's nothing you
could say to me bro my universe has gone
upside down
there's nothing anyone could say to me
this whole friendship's been alive yeah
Jesus 100 yeah that's all I got
um
random one straight to the point when he
asked to smash my girl oh
that is straight to the point straight
to the point and no no one understands
oh bro let me smash your girl please
please please please please please
please please let me bang your girl
that's you we can't be friends
right this one's tweeted me nah I was
the hating friend because all all the
people I was close to left me and became
close together so basically I'm the
common denominator
far that's tough that is tough
especially when you've deeped it but
there's a stage where you deep it but
don't believe it but when you deeply and
see it
wild crumble bam when I'm falling out
with Ellis and falling out with REM
falling out with Jack and falling out
with Jay I'm falling out with tobes I'm
falling out with you all separate
arguments and I'm like [__] all these
man yeah yeah and then you manage just
hanging out together all the time
that realization would be crazy yeah but
you jump into the canal for sure
yeah yeah yeah I'll chew up all the
poison because I wanted to end today
yuck yeah that's crazy who's Consulting
me no even nobody left I'm telling you
Bungalow no stairs the facts
yeah right
not hate but on my graduation day
instead of saying something nice like
congratulations she asked me where I
bought my weave because it looked cheap
water
what bro
that's some hatred boy [__]
are we from look cheap on my graduation
wow
wow that's horrible so
you didn't say it but like um this one's
tweeted me so this is obviously the
original one yeah this is what you like
the first one that you said moved in my
boyfriend but there's two replies I got
the replies you man this sweet me so
obviously the title of the thing is when
did you realize your supposed friend
actually hated you yeah then the one
that you said when she moved in with my
boyfriend then she then she replied said
no way she said yes and she has the same
surname as yours
okay cool
Jesus that's the end of today's
programming it is thank you for coming
guys
um as I said if you enjoyed the content
hand on over to patreon.com shakes and
gigs to get all the bonus episodes keep
an eye out for Daddy yum tum 2023
because I'm super duper serious this
time let's go I'm not gonna do 75 hard
who literally can't be bothered apart
from balance apart from Alice I'm
convinced he's cheating
I'm convinced cheating because he just
seems too sorry yeah he seems he's not
broken down yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
Sony for the strong
oh oh he doesn't blinked since he said
what a way to end the episode only for
the strong say less Ellis say less say
less what day you want by the way before
you lock it off oh Mom
I want to pop my Knuckles up I'm on day
24.
wow that's a fun bike it has gone quick
three in a bit weeks and I said it's
only for the struggle let's Wrap This
[__] Up
let's wrap this [__] up I'm gonna lie
to you man
it's a job because I'm not gonna do it
but you're egging me
because I'll do 76.
wow wow I'll do 76. say that pissed me
off but anyway thank you guys we'll see
you on Thursday
[Music]
foreign